JOHNNY LEE: Hi.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
Thank you very much.
Welcome to day
two of Google I/O,
and thanks for joining
me this afternoon.
Hopefully, the sun hasn't
been too hard on your skin,
and you're not too sunburned.
So today, we'll be talking
about Project Tango
and why we're pushing on this
technology, what we have today,
and I want to share with
you a little bit about where
we hope to go in the future.
The road ahead of us
is really exciting,
and I thank you for
following us on this journey.
So when we open our eyes,
something really amazing
happens.
Light and shadow enter our eyes.
And a large part of our brain--
our whole visual cortex--
starts to go to work and
interprets these signals
into edges and shapes.
And we start to build
a memory of things.
We start to recognize what
our environment looks like.
We know what our
room looks like.
home looks like.
And we start learning
the space around us.
And as we learn
our space, we start
to get familiar with
where it's safe to walk,
where it's not safe to walk,
and how we adjust our movements
even in the slightest way to
avoid bumping into things.
And if any of you
are parents, you
are intimately familiar with,
or can appreciate, the dangers
and pains of misjudging
your space around you, even
just by a few inches.
And some of the things
in our environment
are even more important
to judge correctly.
Even as adults, when
the lights go out,
we can sometimes
take for granted
how important vision is to us.
We start to fumble around
and walk very cautiously.
And the few inches can be the
difference between safe passage
or a dangerous fall.
So our ability to
navigate our space
is pretty fundamental
to our everyday lives.
So just a reminder,
Project Tango
is our focused goal to give our
mobile devices and our tools
this similar level of
perception of space and movement
and, ideally, ultimately unify
how people think about space
and how our tools
think about space.
More and more, our
phones have become
increasingly sophisticated
with more functionality.
Phones used to be phones.
It's actually hard
to remember that.
But now they have cameras that
allow us to augment our memory,
communicate visually with
friends and partners.
The sensors, which
humbly started
to help just with automatic
screen orientation,
like accelerometers
and gyroscopes,
now provide a source of
potentially health analytics
and even activity awareness for
pattern recognition and context
awareness.
And now we're getting
accustomed to simply
being able to unlock our
phones simply by touching them.
And this, then, becomes the
foundation for mobile payments.
So the ability to track
position and track movement
and measure the environment
are such fundamental parts
of how we operate as
people that we see it
as an inevitable direction.
And in fact, we're starting
to see consumer products
coming out in the
past 12 months that
start to incorporate
these capabilities
of positional tracking that
enable new user experiences
or advanced computer
vision to do collision
avoidance in the drone space.
So just a quick reminder,
Project Tango devices
give three capabilities.
There's motion tracking,
which is the ability
to respond to physical movement,
so when I walk forward, left,
or right.
Depth perception,
which is the ability
to measure the
distance to floors,
the walls, and surfaces.
And area learning, which is
basically the device's ability
to have some spatial
memory-- to recognize
places it's been before.
And that can be used to
help with drift correction
or enable multi-player
experiences in the same space.
Now we've had a few sessions
at Google I/O going deeper
into some of these topics, so I
won't be going into much detail
here.
But to achieve these
new capabilities,
we actually have to
introduce new hardware.
And if you've been
following very closely,
you'll be familiar
with some of these.
But I want to give you a sense.
It started about three
years ago with a drawing
that looked like
this, which is just
a proposal for a tablet
that has new sensors
to do tracking, depth sensing,
and [INAUDIBLE] measurement
units.
And so a few months
later in 2013,
we had our very first
Android prototype.
Now it was a very
clunky, bulky prototype.
And it worked, but it
wasn't very pretty.
But you can start
to see that it had
the first components that we
needed to do Project Tango.
We have a sensor dedicated
for motion tracking.
We have integrated
depth sensing,
and then hardware
accelerated vision processing
to do all the computer vision.
A few months later,
we pushed ourselves
to drive down on size.
And we started using mobile
phone class components
and mobile phone class cameras.
And this is important for
manufacturability and cost
down as well as power reduction.
So you may have seen
these as the white phones
a few years ago.
Then we decided to
really push the limits
on processing power with
our tablet development kits.
And this is what we
showed off last year.
These include, again, the
same three components.
And the specifications
for this tablet
were actually well
ahead of their time.
The specifications in
terms of processing power
and RAM and GPU
capability are only
now being matched by phones
being released today,
two years later.
Over the past year,
one of the things
that we've been doing a lot is
working heavily with Qualcomm
to integrate support
for these new hardware
components into their Snapdragon
processor board support
package, or BSP.
And for those of you who
are familiar with how
mobile devices are made, the
BSP is a package of software
that phone
manufacturers, or OEMs,
receive when they want
to build a new phone.
And so this required creating
new hardware abstraction
layers, new changes
to the camera
stack to allow not only
the RGB camera to work,
the motion tracking camera
to work, and the depth sensor
to work all at the same
time, but also things
like accurate time stamping.
And so this means
that any OEM that
wants to build a
Snapdragon-based phone
will already have the
major components they need
to make a Tango-enabled device.
So this unlocks the possibility
for more phones as well as
more form factors, such
as wearables and robotics,
in coming years.
And we're eager to see the
incorporation of these features
into those products.
Now the first of these
products is the Lenovo phone
that we've been working
with over the past year.
You've probably heard
about it from CES.
And you can also see
that it maintains
the same pedigree in terms of
the hardware components inside.
We have the depth sensor,
the motion tracking sensor,
and our vision processing.
Now unfortunately, we won't be
talking much about the phone
today.
You'll have to wait
for Lenovo's Tech World
on June 9 in just a few weeks.
But the event will
be live streamed
for those who can't attend.
Now the hardware is
just part of the story.
And in fact, most of
the Project Tango team
is composed of the software.
So when you combine
all this data,
you have to put it
together into a stack
to interpret the signals
into motion and sensing.
So I wanted to give
you a short video
montage of some of
the journey that we
have from our very
humble beginnings
when we were a very small
team to where we are today.
Could you play the video?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[ROLLER COASTER SOUNDS]
[SCREAMS]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEE: So I'm also
really happy to say
that we've actually incorporated
the basic fundamental APIs
for Tango into
Android N. So what
that means is that if you
target an Android N device,
you'll be able to see
some new sensor types.
You'll see the 6-DOF sensor as
well as a depth sensor camera
type.
And this means that you'll
start to be able to write games
that respond to
the user's motion
or be able to write
apps that can measure
the environment and some of the
things you saw in the video.
Now, remember, it's important
to know that these devices will
only have the APIs
enabled on devices
that have the right hardware.
This is similar to GPS.
If you don't have
GPS modules inside,
the APIs won't be enabled.
And on devices which meet our
Project Tango specifications,
there'll be additional
libraries that
help with things like area
learning, depth, and meshing,
as well as augmented
reality samples that
have to do with things like
time stamping and alignment
with the RGB camera.
But the integration with
the Snapdragon processor
BSP as well as
integration into Android N
lays the groundwork for
many, many new devices
to come out with
these capabilities.
So let me give you
some live demos
of some of those components
working in action.
So if we could switch
over to the tablet
and bring down the lights.
So this is just a
reminder of what's
happening underneath the hood.
This is our motion
tracking sensor.
You can see it's
a fisheye camera
with hardware-accelerated
feature tracks.
And you see in the
upper right-hand corner
how it responds to movement.
And so this is the
underlying piece
of what the 6-DOF
APIs will provide you
if you write an
app in Android N.
And I can walk to this
side of the stage,
walk to this side of the stage,
wave the device up and down.
Wave it up and
down, and it tracks.
So one of the things
we want to give
to people who receive
a Tango device,
a bit of a tutorial
on what it's like
to have these new
capabilities in their phone.
So this is an out-of-the-box
experience that we've built
inside of Unity using our APIs.
And so you can see it uses
a depth sensor to actually
provide a point cloud
of the environment
and illustrates the fact
that we're indeed capturing
a 3D model of the scene.
And we have some visitors.
And if we walk forward,
we can get closer to them.
You see the edge
of the stage there.
[APPLAUSE]
So as I look around, I can
get closer to the flowers.
And it starts to build this
virtual environment around me
with plants and creatures.
And then we're visited
by some friends.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: Ah.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEE: So you can create
really wonderful experiences
when you combine all the
different pieces together--
you combine tracking
with depth sensing
and the passthrough
camera to transition
between a hand-held VR
experience and a hand-held AR
experience.
Now we can get down to slightly
more utilitarian use cases.
Actually, I want to keep
the lights down for this.
And so this is our
updated measurement app.
We just call it Measure It.
And what it does is
it shows another way
of combining the APIs to
provide value to the user.
So if we wanted to measure
the width of this cabinet,
you can see that we actually
have a slightly updated
UI here.
We have this circular
radical with a green dot
that wobbles around.
The reason why there's a
wobble is because what it does
is it looks for interesting
features to lock onto.
So when I get
close to this edge,
you can actually see it snaps
to the edge of the cabinet.
And what this does,
it allows me to get
a very good snap of that wall.
[APPLAUSE]
We can also do something
a little bit fancier.
So let me place a marker there.
And it also tries to
maintain right angles.
But what's also very cool
is we can now do volumes.
So if I walk backwards, I can
actually strike out a box.
[APPLAUSE]
And you can see all the
different measurements
overlaid onto the edge.
So that's two foot, four inches
thereabouts on each dimension.
And if I take a picture of this,
it'll save it to my gallery.
And so if I'm working on some
new cabinetry or kitchen work,
I can simply take this picture.
And you can see
on the right side,
it shows a picture
on the left side,
but then a schematic
view on the right side
where it shows an
orthographic view.
And you can take this to
the hardware store and say,
this is approximately the size
of the cabinets I'm working on.
[APPLAUSE]
Now being able to understand
the physical size of things
is really interesting.
So this is an app
from Wayfair, who's
one of the world's largest
online retailers of furniture.
And when you're shopping
online for furniture,
you typically have to
scroll through a large set
of thumbnails of
couches and lamps.
And you have to guess-- oh,
will you keep the lights down
for this, actually?
You sort of have to
guess, how big is it?
Is it actually going
to fit in my room?
Do I have enough space?
So what Wayfair
has done is started
working with furniture
suppliers to acquire
3D models of the furniture
in their web store.
So I have all small
collection here.
And we can select some items.
And let me see how
this chair looks.
And if I pick a place
on the floor, I drop it.
That's the loading progress bar.
And it unpacks the
box in front of me.
[APPLAUSE]
So again, we get all the
correct dimensions of the chair.
We can look at it
from different angles.
We can decide if
we like the fabric
or how many chairs we can
actually get into the space.
So let me pick another item.
You can see this lonely
table right here.
So let's pick this lamp.
Again, that's a 3D progress bar.
And we can lay down the
lamp on top of the table
and do the same thing.
Now you'll notice on
the bottom, there's
actually this shopping
cart with a plus button.
I'm not connected to
the Wi-Fi right now,
but that button actually works.
It will actually populate
Wayfair's main mobile app.
And you can then make
the purchase there.
So this actually helps
a lot because one
of the problems with
online retailers,
especially in the
furniture space,
is that you often
get a lot of returns.
And so what this can
do is prevent or reduce
the amount of issues
that you'll have.
Now this one, we can
keep the lights up.
So you'll see I actually
have this other toy here.
And one of the
things, of course,
we can do-- the
measurement and shopping.
But another thing
we can do is games.
Now some of you at
I/O last year may
have seen a version of
this kind of mechanic.
But this is a demo where
it's a much simplified
version to give you a sense
of the subtlety and the type
of interaction you can enable.
So the volume may be a
little high for this one.
We'll check.
We'll see.
There we go.
So this is basically a
target practice game.
And you imagine you're
in a training scenario.
And I can look around and see
all the different targets.
Now if I just stand in one
place and pull the trigger,
it actually shoots this
kickball back at me.
I see this red ball.
And it comes and
[SHATTERING SOUND]
hits me back in the face.
In order to do
well in this game,
you actually have to dodge
the ball that comes back.
So if I shoot and take a step
to the side, [SHATTERING SOUND]
you can see that the
ball goes past my head.
So if you actually really
want to do well at this game,
you have to constantly move.
[SHATTERING SOUNDS]
[AIR HORN] [SHATTERING SOUNDS]
And you can also see
there's this tree here
[SHATTERING SOUND] that you
actually have to look around
to see all the targets.
[SHATTERING SOUNDS] So
that's just another example of
the range of experiences you
can do.
[APPLAUSE]
I got to get the
device out of the rig.
There we go.
So this last demo is actually
from the American Museum
of Natural History in New York.
And what they have
there is an exhibit
on the evolution of
dinosaurs to modern birds.
And this app was
built in conjunction
with the help of Guidigo.
And what they've done is
they've taken-- sorry,
I'm a little bit out of breath.
Whew.
But what they've done is
they've taken the assets
from their exhibit in
the museum and allowed
you to create an AR experience
at home with those assets.
So let's bring the
lights back down.
So we have on the
right, it's actually
similar to the
furniture shopping app.
You can now search
for dinosaurs.
So we all love the velociraptor.
Thanks to "Jurassic
Park," that's
a very well-understood creature.
So the polygonal model is
actually the aesthetic style
they chose for the exhibit.
And they chose it to
maintain scientific accuracy
because they don't actually know
the exact details of the skin
texture.
And so rather than
have a false texture,
they decided to give a
more abstract figure.
So you can see, he's
here in front of me.
He's interacting.
If I push this little
plus button on the right,
he actually pauses and
gives me these info buttons.
So if I walk up to the
tail, I can click on it.
And it gives me a little
bit more information
about this particular
feature of the body.
Or I go here, and I can
learn a little bit more
about his wings.
Now, what's also cute is if I
could have my lovely assistant
come up-- Clay [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
Let me start it over so
the animation will play.
They've actually added
this little camera button
on the bottom.
And you can essentially
do dinosaur selfies here.
Three, two, one.
There you go.
And then email this
to your friend.
Thanks, Clay.
[APPLAUSE AND WHISTLES]
Actually, this one demo,
we'll see if it works.
I actually didn't test
this one quite as much.
But if it works, it'll be fun.
So some dinosaurs are big.
There we go.
So he doesn't look too big, but
if you go in the upper right,
that's because he's at 20% size.
And we have a little
plus button here,.
And we can start to get
a picture of exactly how
big he is in real life.
There you go.
Hey buddy. [DINOSAUR ROAR]
He's harmless.
He's friendly.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's go back to the slides.
So you just saw
five or six demos
of apps that are either
already in the Play store
or in progress for
launch later this year.
And this is just
a small selection
of dozens of apps that are
already in the Play store.
So I want to give you a
quick little montage of some
of the other apps that
are in progress that I
didn't have time to demo today.
So play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEE: So just
a reminder, if you
want to build a Project
Tango enabled app,
you use standard Android
development processes
and tools and publishing.
Your app just goes
up on the Play store,
and your app has
access to the APIs
and detects them if
they're on the device.
So we have C, C++, Java, Unity,
and Unreal support with sample
code.
And you can actually
write one APK
that you can distribute
to all Android devices.
And if you have the
right code in it,
if it gets downloaded on
a Tango-enabled device,
you can check for those APIs and
unlock new features in your app
with a single distribution.
So that's where we are.
But obviously, the thing
we started with Tango
is sort of a journey.
And we're definitely
not done with that
because we're very much
in the early stages.
And I know almost
everybody says that.
But I actually
really believe that.
We're really just starting
to scratch the surface.
These APIs just start to unlock
very superficial capabilities
of what you can start to
do with basic movement.
But completely understanding
our environment
and the objects
in it is actually
still an open challenge.
For example, I know
that the podium here
has walls on the back
sides of the podium,
but my device actually
doesn't know that yet.
The depth sensor only tells
it about the front surfaces.
It also doesn't know that
the podium is potentially
composed of many, many
different objects.
There's a shelf here and
some equipment underneath.
And it treats it basically
as one large set of geometry.
So we also can't
tell, for example,
what the amphitheater
might look like at night
simply by seeing it
once during the day.
And that's something
we've developed
this immense human capacity
and experience to actually
be able to do.
And these problems
aren't actually
going to be solved in the
next one to two years.
So we actually view that it's
similar to these other efforts.
Working on improved
speech understanding
so that you can have more
sophisticated interactions
with just your voice.
We can allow cars to
navigate traffic and safely
transport us home.
Or investments in machine
learning like AlphaGo
to tackle increasingly
difficult or ambiguous problems.
So the Project Tango
team is invested
in focusing on giving our
tools this perception of space
and movement at a human scale.
And we actually believe
we can't do it alone.
The challenges here are so
large that many of the things,
just like the ones
I described to you,
are built on
decades of research.
And Tango, really,
is no different.
Some of the same concepts used
in our sensor fusion stack
have pedigree in the work
done for space exploration
and robotics.
The researchers had to
combine the raw data
from the cameras and the
IMU data on the rovers
to estimate its motion on Mars.
And even some of
the researchers that
worked on this
original Rover are
involved in Project
Tango in various ways.
So we stand on the
shoulders of giants.
And taking on this understanding
is really no small task.
And it's actually
the reason why we
maintain a very open
collaboration with research
partners.
And in fact, we have over 10
research partner institutions--
either research labs
or universities--
that we fund for
doing research work.
Over 26 conference journals,
conference papers or journals,
and 25 PhDs and master's
students in various ways
have been involved
in the project,
all contributing over 50,000
lines of open source code.
Now I want to show you
a quick video of things
that are in progress or
in development as part
of these research efforts.
Some of these are
done internally,
but also some of them are
done by our external partners.
And these aren't things that
are committed to the product
roadmap, but they're
very much thinking
about the direction
we want to go
and things we hope to one
day become mature enough
to be developer tools.
So if we could play this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEE: So just as with
the introduction of GPS,
it enabled new industries
and new functionality that
wasn't really possible before.
But as these technologies
find their way
into phones and
into our pockets,
it suddenly became possible
to navigate new spaces.
You can now press
a button and a car
will appear and drive to you.
You can find the nearest
pizza or find a friend nearby.
And the impact of
the technology far
exceeds what it was first
initially conceived for.
And so we imagine,
wouldn't it be
great to have a tool
that would allow
you to find rooms and places
that you've never been before?
Or wouldn't it be great
to have a device that
could help the visually
impaired navigate through spaces
with greater confidence
or greater independence?
It would be great if
emergency workers had
a tool that could
let them estimate
the positions of their
teammates in a disaster
area in real time.
Or it would be great
to have the ability
to walk through stories
without tethers or cables.
It would be great if we
could increase the speed
or efficiency of
package delivery
or even allow supplies to
reach remote locations.
And one day, it would be nice
to have robotic systems that
share our perception
of physical space
to be better collaborators
with their human counterparts.
So we're seeking people who
want to build a future with us.
And we want to find
colleagues in this space.
So just a reminder,
everything you just saw,
including the things
in the research video,
were done with our Tango
tablets and the data
that they're actually
able to capture.
And these are available
on the Google Store today.
You can find the link
from our website.
And later this year, we'll
see the first consumer device
with these capabilities in it
with the project with Lenovo.
I also want to give a
shout out and thank you
for all the partners that
we have demo-ing here
at the Sandbox or
were participating
in the panel earlier today.
If you haven't had a chance
to go to the Sandbox,
I think it's right
by that corner
and you can try
some of the demos.
In the after hours this evening,
we also have a treat for you.
We actually have a
20-person multi-player game
where you can battle
against aliens
in a game called Phantogeist
from Tricksy Studios.
It'll be 8:00 PM in the
Cassiopeia tent, which
I think is in that direction.
So that should be fun.
There's also a dedicated
session tomorrow
on making six degree of freedom
gaming with Project Tango.
So I encourage you to see
that tomorrow at 10:00 AM.
And we want to help.
Now, we don't have an infinite
number of people on our team
to do it, but there are
some mechanics-- ways
that we try to help you
create really great apps.
First of all, we have
periodic workshops.
We have developer
engineering support.
We also have the opportunity
to feature your app on devices
that may be coming out or
featuring it in our Tango app
portal if you work with us.
We can connect
clients with partners.
We talk with a lot of
different companies.
And sometimes,
people have assets
and they simply need
a viewing application,
or there are opportunities
for connections that we
might be able to help with.
And periodically, we
have application RFPs
or even competitions
we'll announce.
So to keep in touch,
we have our website.
We have our support email.
We also have a reasonably robust
Google+ page with over 8,000
developers regularly posting
updates about related news
as well as their own apps
and their Twitter handle.
So I'll leave this page
up for those of you
that want a picture of it.
Thank you very much for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]